[Musique]
Yael Bron pivé présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale en visite à La Réunion a
rencontré ce lundi 8 janvier le
collectif pour l'élimination des
violences
intrafamiliales l'occasion pour le
département de rappeler son engagement
en faveur de ses victimes la
collectivité a consacré 1300000 € en
2023 en soutien des intervenants de
terrain je crois que il faut absolument
encourager la mobilisation de tous et on
voit ici à travers la table ronde que
nous avons eu que chacun se mobilise et
que la coordination de tous ces acteurs
fait qu'on peut avoir des résultats donc
je voulais vraiment avoir ces échanges
parce qu'on sait qu'à la Réunion c'est
un sujet et un phénomène qui est
d'ampleur et qui préoccupe tous les élus
tous les acteurs tous les réunionnais et
donc il était important pour moi pour
nous d'avoir ce premier échange consacré
à ce sujet un peu plus tard dans
l'après-midi cyril melkur a reçu Bron
pivé au palais de la source après lui
avoir fait visiter l'hémicycle le
président du Département a reçu la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale dans
son bureau où de nombreux sujets ont été
abordés ce sont des sujets qui touchent
les réunionn dans leur quotidien les
sujets à caractère social on a parlé
bien évidemment du
vieillissement de notre rattrapage dans
les politiques du handicap à la Réunion
on a abordé les sujets de développement
de l'
avec tout ce qui touche au développement
agricole à la sécurité alimentaire le
sujet de l'obtroit de mer vaste sujet
puis que nous sommes à l'obre de
discussion autour de son avenir l'avenir
de cette recette fiscale et j'ai abordé
un sujet qui me paraît essentiel c'est
celui de l'insertion des publics
éloignés de l'emploi notamment des
publics bénéfici du RSA avec
l'expérimentation qui est menée à
travers France travail nous avons
également discuter des atouts de la
Réunion parce que il ne faudrait pas ne
voir que ces difficultés qui existe il
ne faut pas les nier mais ses atouts
notamment son domaine maritime notamment
son agriculture il y a beaucoup à faire
mais beaucoup est déjà fait et beaucoup
est fait c'est je trouve très important
de le noter et de le saluer en bonne
intelligence on voit que les acteurs
travaillent très bien ensemble que ce
soit la présidente de région le
président du conseil départemental avec
les services de l'État les élus locaux
entre eux et pour moi et pour nous c'est
très important en tant qu'élu de la
nation de pouvoir constater cette bonne
intelligence au niveau local le
lendemain mardi 9 janvier Cyril Melkor a
accueilli la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale au Lazar de la grande
chaloupebron PIV a pu découvrir ce haut
lieu de la mémoire réunionnaise où des
milliers de travailleurs engagés sont
passé
important de regarder son passé les yeux
grand ouverts et c'est un vrai lieu de
mémoire important pour les Réunionnais
puisque on voit que non seulement il
appartient à l'histoire de la Réunion
mais qu'il appartient aussi à son
présent puisqu'il a participé les habit
les personnes qui sont venues et qui ont
transité ici ont participé à la
construction et au peuplement de lîle
donc pour moi en tant que président de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est important de
pouvoir venir honorer ces personnes et
puis aussi de
le travail qui est fait par les
associations par les élus parce que sans
eux ces lieux n'existeraient plus et
nous avons besoin de l'effort de chacun
pour pouvoir leur permettre d'exister et
pouvoir permettre de nous unir autour de
notre passé pour mieux envisager
l'avenir ensemble une visite qui
constitue une première pour une
personnalité de ce rang lors d'un voyage
officiel l'histoire de la Réunion c'est
aussi l'histoire de son peuplement c'est
l'histoire des souffrances de ceux et
celles qui sont venus par bateau soit au
titre de l'esclavage ou alors de
langagisme et lorsque cette visite a
lieu ici au lazaret c'est toute la
partie de l'angagisme qui se trouve
revalorisée reconnu et nous voulons dire
que de cette histoire douloureuse à Ja
une société apaisée c'est pour cela que
cette visite elle est hautement
symbolique et hautement importante la
visite s'est achevée par un moment de
recueil pctué d'une minute de silence et
d'un dépôt de
gerbe la journée s'est poursuivie dans
la commune du port où yel Bron Pivet a
échangé avec l'association l'Office la
langue créole une séquence à laquelle a
participé Isabelle erudel conseillère
départemental mais aussi professeur des
écoles qui a une classe bilingue créole
français plus tard dans la journée la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
visité l'usine du Gaul de Saint-Louis a
été abordé le thème de la transition
énergétique
la journée s'est achevée à la Plaine des
Cafres sur l'exploitation de Monsieur
Robert agriculteur et président de la
SIC revia pour parler autonomie
alimentaire enfin ce mercredi 10 janvier
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
s'est rendue à la marapouo à Salazie au
croisement entre la RD48 et le Stier qui
mène à laamar lui ont été présenté les
actions mises en place pour prévenir les
risques naturels autant de
population